yeah welcome to a new video cuz I posted
the videos yesterday a couple of viewers
suggested that I try 15-minute games and
well I thought I'd give it a try
only thing is I never played a 15-minute
game here on on a sec so I started you
with 1,600 rating so I guess the first
couple of opponents are rather weak
rating wise let's see I wanted to go for
for a nympho or Queens inion type of
opening but he he played Bishop g5 go h6
first trying to for some declaration of
this Bishop okay so we retreated okay
this this check should be it should be
fine yeah now we actually transposed to
in Dominion at some just identical to
two for Bishop g5 in the names own now I
think it's called leningrad variation
yeah one possibility is here to take and
twin a5 then he cannot cannot take on f6
because he three sang with check and he
will lose all kind of material okay
I played this first and then now c3 is
detect of course and yeah
yeah now I basically have have to two
possibilities I can just take on d4 and
win a pawn for ya for not much you could
also consider the tricky move Knight e4
because he cannot take with the Queen
because of CC c3 hanging like I just I
just take this one yeah it's just an
extra pawn and also Queen c3 what
yeah now could could just take with the
Queen and go into an endgame with the
next report and also the better
structure
yeah I saw something better don't think
so okay let's go for this endgame so now
you should decide what what's the best
setup here
well c5 is a natural square for the
knight so it should go to c5 and one
thing I should be aware of that wide my
place he 5 himself so maybe it's a good
idea to start with a move that controls
on the square maybe just b6
yeah he can play c5 then try to get rid
of this weakness but I don't want to
allow him to play c5 himself so it would
hinder most be 6 and d6 if he manages to
play this so I tried to get this in and
he's playing very quickly so he really
needs to okay he really needed to play
c5 now I'll even get this great position
for the knight on c5 ok yeah this night
might be used to to exchange off the c5
Knight on on d3 for instance f2 d3 or
you might try to attack the f6 pawn with
9 FY h 5 but anyway this is some these
rules
so maybe now we're in the way where
should this bishop gone I guess a 6c for
a weakness after all and now maybe just
king is heaven and double on the sea far
is it a difference of her play Roxy I'd
immediately not really yeah the only
weakness here is age 6 + f6 probably but
the king is covering this nicely and h6
is very hard to attack so it's not a big
deal okay now trying to develop on c4
yeah maybe just take and rook c8 now
this is a tech three times and it will
come with Roxy one of course now now I
can play b5 in or d5 two to use the the
pin of this pawn but b5 would be
answered with c5 so I guess just d5 they
cannot take here this should win the c4
pawn
yeah he's played this really quickly
very much like a five-minute game and
the main difference is that I just have
more time to to talk about various
aspects iam okay I can just exchange
more here it goes to the king opponent
game yeah I can just push those pawns
home only should check quickly that
there's no breakthrough or something
some city trick here okay let's get some
points for what
yeah okay I'll pick this one now he's
got h5 but I'm in time to to catch this
okay yeah no stay away please next move
checkmate yeah this was her rating gain
of 320 points the first couple of games
are always like this if you start a new
a new rating pool here so it was really
quick for a 15 minute game but well it
happens yeah basically I think I'm not
sure maybe maybe even a 3-year son it's
really problematic it's not not easy to
see how it should should cover c3 now
without allowing me to for instance take
on d4 or play 94 or something the bishop
on G on h4 is somewhat sightlines here
so this is already already problem
usually white answers here with d5 or
maybe Knight f3 form from one
alternative but g5 versus a normal move
and then black usually captures on c3
and so on so this was just went out of
the opening of here it's it's just
winning winning already okay let's try
another game with the 15-minute time
control